[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 118 over the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
Mok Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Warrick Mele how are
you doing today hi mark I'm here you're
here that's the important part you're
not an SF but you've been a little under
the weather unfortunately and now I've
been a little under the weather and I'm
glad to hear you're doing better thank
you
so this week we have a really great
episode with Morgan McLean and gbd from
open census coming to talk to us all
about this open source project which is
super super exciting
yes definitely as always we like to kick
off our podcast with cool things of the
week and end with the question and this
week's question is I heard there are
abilities to natively extend kubernetes
what does that mean and also how do I do
that and you know as always god only
knows where that question might have
come from maybe me
it might have been for me maybe maybe
maybe maybe not so to kick off our cool
things of the week for tensorflow
they're already at release 1.6 which is
impressive considering I know they just
released 1.5 not too long ago yes they
also have their dev summit coming up at
the end of this month on March 30th and
we'll provide a link in the show notes
and our colleagues
Ayutthaya and Sarah both came together
and did a video recently I know you
things been doing a number of videos on
AI and they discussed how you can do
tensorflow object detection in iOS and
they basically build a custom object
detection mobile app and so we'll
include a link to that video awesome
cool so this week I'm gonna plug one of
my own things which is kind of cool and
exciting I've been working with Ubisoft
and a bunch of Googlers as well and a
bunch of other airsoft employees to work
on a open source dedicated game server
hosting open source project it's called
ago Nez I will put a link to the github
in the show notes as well as the blog
post announcing it all but it's an open
source project for running dedicated
game servers for like real-time
multiplayer games at scale on top of
gruba Nettie's so some of you may have
seen some of my blog posts talking about
doing that kind of stuff this is
essentially a product ization of that
running has an open source project so
I'm pretty excited about it and we want
a lot of people to get involved so if
this sounds interesting to you please
come join us on the github and
the Google Group and follow us on
Twitter you were very hard on this this
is definitely a wonderful achievement
I'm pretty excited you should be should
be I can't wait to hear when it's
applied to something like what the first
game it gets applied to yeah we're doing
stuff we're doing stuff but yeah lots of
details in the blog post for sure
thirdly we have a blog post by a fella
developer advocate Colt McAnlis he has a
bunch of really nice tips and tricks for
optimizing performance on Google Cloud
storage specifically around uploading
and downloading files he has a bunch of
best practices for say like smaller
files versus bigger files different
command-line parameters you can try all
sorts of interesting tips and tricks
this is one I particularly like which is
avoiding the sequencing naming
bottleneck he talks actually about how
the namings of your files can actually
impact the performance of uploading
files into Google Ad storage and why
that actually is so yeah if you do a lot
of stuff with Google Cloud storage you
might want to check this out because
it's particularly interesting to make
sure you can get the biggest bang for
your buck definitely and last but not
least we also want to mention that GCP
has a new interactive CLI yeah this is
super cool I'm excited about this it
actually really is the blog post itself
shows the CLI in action and gives you a
visual understanding of what it looks
like pretty neat because as you type it
does autocomplete and then it's also
showing definitions and information and
I screen below it's basically kind of
having the screen and as you type you
can see what's going on below that it
reminds me a little bit of Jupiter
notebooks nice Evan play with Jupiter
Network yeah I was gonna say it's not
exactly the same but it's similar
interesting no and is what I like about
this is it works for G cloud GS util the
beaker util so PQ and cube CCL and yeah
I'm I'm actually really excited to give
this a shot so G cloud alpha interactive
is the command to start it and really I
don't really want to play with it this
looks really cool yeah with you anything
that allows you to use the CLI more
effectively makes me happy alright well
mark I think it might be time for us to
go talk with our guests let's go do that
then
today I'm very happy to have two people
from the our consensus team joining us
today we have Morgan McLain did I get
that right is it
Slynt product manager for open senses as
well as jbd software engineer joining us
today how are you both doing great how
are you
well good super happy to have you both
here I've been wanting to talk about
open senses for ages now he can attest
to that but before we get stuck into
that I'd love to hear more about who you
both are and what you do at Google
Morgan why don't we start with you sure
Google for about two years I'm the
product manager for tracing debugging
and profiling this includes our some of
our internal tools as well as those
under the stackdriver brand one of the
biggest things that I've been feeling in
the last few years is open census which
is why I'm here to talk to you about it
Jim Eadie I'm an engineer working on
open census I'm actually pretty new in
this field but I have quite significant
background in building developer
platforms and tools in the recent years
I was actually focused on diagnostic
tools of the go programming language and
I kind of like you know switch to this
area maybe we came to passionate too
easily
because you know there are tons of
potential and lots of gaps I need you
used to sit next to me but now you don't
anymore this seems like a good program
manager question which is always fun but
I'll be interested to hear the
difference in response at a high level
so what is open census what is this
project yes is a single distribution of
language specific libraries that pull
data of instrumentation and telemetry
out of your application so you can
analyze the a performance later on so to
start with we're focusing on distributed
choices and metrics so to put that even
more succinctly open census gives you a
really easy way to pull traces and
metrics out of your app who would be
somebody that would use this primarily
developers of distributed services so
open census stems from a lot of our
learnings at Google when we wanted to
build distributed tracing distributed
metrics in a big way at high scale but
it really lives if a benefice open
census are applicable to anybody
building you know services with some
amount of scale so you use two terms
their metrics
tracing yes what what are those things
what's metrics what's tracing what are
those what are those two words mean so I
imagine a lot of listeners to the
podcast are familiar with metrics so you
know traditionally you'll pull things
like CPU consumption or memory
consumption out of any of the nodes that
are hosting your application and and
it's you know a fairly well solve
problem open census focuses on app level
metrics
so pulling out things like the number of
requests made to your application or the
latency of those requests as well as any
other metrics that you want to build
into your code in a custom way which is
a little more difficult to pull out
these days the other term distributed
tracing is probably one of the people
are less familiar with so for those who
don't know a distributed trace
let's see watch a single request as it
propagates across all of your services
so for example if you have an e-commerce
application and a customer comes in
requests the cart service to add an item
to their shopping cart you might get
calls to that shopping cart service that
then propagate down to maybe a catalogue
service and others and a single
distributor trays shows you that entire
chain of requests that was based off the
single action made by the customer and
so it's really useful for a couple
reasons first to determine how your
system operates if you're not already
familiar with it and that's at a very
basic level but additionally each hop
along the way shows you the latency and
so when you want to reduce the latency
of your application which becomes really
important as it grows distributed
tracing is a great way to do that and
finally if you have an error during that
quest the trace effectively works like a
really long and powerful call stack
right so you can you can actually see
what happened that let there and I my
understanding is that open census is
cloud agnostic this is used for any kind
of distributed system is that right
yeah correct we are not dependent on you
know any any cloud provider or metric
collection or tracing back-end we
collect data from your app or your
services or frameworks in a vendor
agnostic way and then export them to
specific backends so it can run anywhere
and against you know any of the
supported backends what sort of a
backends do you support currently the
support is dependent on the language
because lots of exporters are work in
progress so go
we support Zipkin stack driver and
Rieger for tracing parameters and driver
monitoring for metric collection can you
also tell us a little more about the
work that you do yeah I was actually
about to like it a little bit of to the
question of what do we do in terms of
like metric collection is Morgan
mentioned that we are in a
general-purpose library so you can
collect metrics on the measures you
define it could be related to your
business cases such as you know number
of transactions if you are
pavement provider or you know number of
you know videos you have processed if
you are generating gifts from you know
videos but on top of that we have some
canonical metrics for protocols such as
HTTP and RPC frameworks such as you know
the latency distribution or request or
response size and I think that's where
open census is becoming more powerful
because all these frameworks can expose
these canonical metrics and you just
plug them to our exporter and get them
out of the box without doing much it
sounds also like a good reason why you
want to use something like open census
rather than just pushing data straight
to something like stackdriver or
Prometheus or something like that it's
giving you tools above and beyond what
the what the backends you provide also
give you there again represented in the
backend somehow but it gives these
frameworks to actually instrument
without depending on any vendor and it's
very powerful
no framework can be open-ended enough to
say that I'm just going to be you know
using the parameters instrumentation
library and this is the only exposition
format I will support because you know
we widely depend on different backends
and that's where open census shines
because very vendor agnostic suite so
actually a Dipity you're probably a
great person to ask for this like as a
developer if I'm sitting down and I'm
like I want to use open census with
maybe an HTTP or I'm guessing how does
that look what does that process look
like yeah we currently support HTTP ng
RPC both and we usually expect users to
start with our framework integrations
you pull the library and you pull the
integration actually for Java ERP C Java
is coming with open senses integration
out of the box so you know you don't
have to do any additional thing in order
to turn it on and on top of that you
know you enable some exporters if you
want to export the data to the backend
we expect users to start with this
framework integrations and on top of
that you know if they have any fine
grained measurements depending on their
technical requirements or their business
cases we expect them to you know create
custom traces or custom measures and
collect more metrics but we expect
people to depend on the framework
integrate
it gives organizations such an advantage
to deploy this widely all across their
stack very easily and it's like one of
the key things that we want to achieve
open census or any any instrumentation
layer is just you know more useful if
you can you know deploy it all across
the stack without much effort nice um
you mentioned Java and go Morgan what
what languages is supported yes so right
now we've really good support across
Java go and C++ for most tracing and
stats and I believe we're tracing
support for Ruby Python and PHP on top
of that eventually our goal and we're
already working towards this is to get
tracing and stat support across Java go
C++ dotnet nodejs Ruby Python PHP and
I'm missing one yeah know which one am I
missing nothing
Erlang still I might still be missing
another one but yeah so since this is an
open project
how can people contribute that are not
necessarily at Google or how can people
contribute in general it's very
straightforward you you know go to our
github organization pick the language
implementation you wanna so we actually
have to be grabbed we have language
implementations but on top of that we
also have a specs repo where we discuss
you know the concepts and the overall
design issues if you want to contribute
to the design issues and the concepts
you go to the specs repo either you know
start an issue or start doing a pull
request if it's a trivial change that
can be you know handled in the cup of a
PR and contributed that way if you want
to contribute to the language
implementations you need to go to the
language implementation repo and again
you know the we have contributing Docs
so you just follow the steps and
contribute server to most open source
projects Pearson yeah exactly yet yes it
also sounds like at Google or at least
coming out of Google and in some other
ways we've got a lot of projects that
seems to be doing related sort of things
I'm thinking like we were talking about
to your PC just a little bit ago
SEO seems to come to mind as well is
there overlap there I mean you said you
support your PC but is there overlap
from like gee our PC or SEO
without consensus or like hooks or
anything special going on there yeah
it's kind of interesting because just to
give you a bit of history like open
census is an open source version that's
been called census which is our
instrumentation framework that we use
inside of Google and in many ways GRDC
and envoy are equivalents of these
systems that census aside Google hooks
into and so interestingly with these
other projects being open source at the
same time we've a big opportunity to
integrate with something to give
external developers the same experience
we have inside of Google for basically
automatic tracing all requests to
propagate through our network and so to
answer your question a little more
succinctly than yes yeah so we've
already built automatic integration for
G RPC we're building automatic
integration for Envoy right now and so
envoy of course is the application side
car component of the Sto project and
then for the sto mixer which is another
part of the SDO project we have some
designs that we'll start working on
shortly for doing things like tracing
aggregation so you can you know capture
traces and configure your back-end a
little more efficiently Morgan you're
talking a little bit about the history
but how did it go from being census to
open census yeah it's actually a really
good question we the blog post coming
out on the syn so there were a couple of
factors at play for one the census team
had simply been wanting to open-source
their work for quite some time and
Google has a long history of open
sourcing projects even when there's no
sort of ulterior motive to doing it just
because teams inside are encouraged to
do that and make things available to the
community next on sack driver trace we
were developing our own instrumentation
libraries right so this effort is in the
long run is going to be replaced with
open census and the cost of developing
these libraries is any vendor in the
industry can attest to is rather high
and on top of that the cost of
maintaining these libraries because you
have to have these integrations into
various web frameworks across so many
languages just continues to behind and
so you have these very large teams who
are just ensuring that your tracing
system can work with you know framework
X on language Y and so we were hoping to
find a more creative solution to
addressing that both for us and our
competitors and then finally at Google
there was a need particularly on the
storage teams to get more
instrumentation into cloud client
libraries so particularly services like
BigTable and spanner you know customers
do sometimes that performance
and we need a quicker way of determining
if that's due to something happening on
the customers end maybe they're calling
an API in a way that we don't really
recommend the way it's not designed for
or maybe there's legitimately a problem
on the service and those teams in the
past have lacked a lot of insight into
that so resolving some customer
performance issues would take days right
or even just more hours than they would
want and so you know getting a way for
them to get a both trace requests going
through from their client libraries to
our services and also just ensure that
they can give us some more
instrumentation to customers regardless
of whatever tracing or metrics back-end
that they're using so not just stack
drive and so really the decision to
release and and so heavily funds the
open census project was due to a
culmination of these factors right and
there was sort of this perfect storm of
wanting to open-source things that our
own tracing product needed better
rotation and then teams at Google wanted
the customers to gain much more insight
into their client libraries and it
worked out really well I could
definitely see the value of having that
holistic picture and being able to sort
of remove from being specifically
affiliated to a certain product or
service because that way you can drive
after that holistic tracing yeah yeah
much more challenging conversation of
our partners in particular if we just
went to the more like yeah this is the
libraries we're credit for our own you
know stackdriver tracing product you
should use them to write like a lot of
partners wouldn't take that seriously
for very good reasons right and then
they'd be somewhat suspicious of it but
it's interesting you know when we meet
with other vendors particularly other
vendors in the space who are also cloud
vendors like ourselves or release own
large well-used api's they have the
exact same challenges and so it becomes
a very straightforward conversation
because we say hey you can embed this
into your client libraries as well and
it turns out you know I suspect I don't
know this for certain but I suspect that
the other cloud vendors you know they
also want us to work when people are
using you know third-party tracing
applications not just the room and so
the fact that this is an open project
and it's going to be gaining a lot more
partners in the future is very appealing
as a maintainer of some of these client
libraries we finally realize that you
know there's no point of having no
vendor agnostic solution and I think
within the go programming language scope
we were actually thinking about maybe we
should have a you know some tracing and
some sort of like instrumentation
library not just racing but metrics in a
standard library but it became quite a
clear case that this is not just
one language you know any organization
you go they depend on three or four
languages so you need to be able to you
know provide this all across different
languages and then I saw the actual
clear benefit of open census and just
decided to you know join this project
rather than you know doing things in my
own corner yeah so I mean it sounds
actually like that the whole vision of
it sounds amazing in that in theory if I
set this up in our consensus inside my
application I could have metrics and
tracing that goes all the way through
from my custom application code all the
way through to the SDKs that I use they
integrate with the cloud that I'm on
yeah and and then potentially other
clouds or other places around us you
mean they also that sounds kind of
Awesome yeah really yes and there's
there's also an additional wire format
standardization effort so lots of
vendors want to also standardize how we
propagate the trace ideas around so if a
trace for example has been started in
you know somewhere in a doubly as x-ray
we will be able to understand it and
like you know keep adding more to that
trace and so on so there's a big effort
all across other vendors to finally you
know create this agnostic view so we can
actually gather you know the
instrumentation data and utilize it what
are additional future enhancements or
connections are you working on yeah
we've got a couple things when we look
sort of longer term sort of through the
end of 2018 for open census one is
something that we've called just you've
got several different names but it's you
know sort of retroactive tracing or
delayed sampling so but it's effectively
it's making a decision on whether you
want to trace a request not at the
beginning so not when the request comes
in and hits your load balancer your very
first service but later on and what this
would enable is selectively sampling
requests that had errors for example or
requests that have higher latency this
is not a trivial thing to achieve but we
think we can do it and we want to add it
to open census for all vendors to take
advantage of if I look at more and sort
of the breadth for open census there's a
couple sort of big rocks that we want to
focus on the biggest would be errors and
blocks and so we you know we haven't put
a ton of thought into this yet but one
of the biggest advantages that we see
our telemetry systems internally inside
of Google is being able to link
traces to logs
or traces to other signals basically
being able to take the context of a
request where something happened and
include that on any other signals
associated with that request and we've
also seen that being very effective with
spectra portrays our customers on Google
App Engine to get this built in and it's
sort of annoyingly hard to pull this off
today with when you have like separate
tracing and logging and error reporting
and profiling in other libraries right
because most of Nolan for each other you
might be using libraries from different
vendors but if we bring this into open
census and you know it actually starts
gaining traction achieved some amount of
popularity everyone can benefit even
vendors who only offer a single feature
like maybe he's logging right or only
tracing can benefit from that
correlation signals and their customers
can benefit from being able to go from a
trace that might be in a zip code and
tie that into you know some metrics that
are in Prometheus or logs stored
somewhere else and that's that's really
like one of the big big things that we
want to drive long-term open census is
that correlation between signals that I
was gonna lead into a question I was
thinking about as you're saying it which
is you do both tracing and metrics like
why do you put those two things together
part of it's just that those are sort of
two areas in the market where we saw a
need for some amount of perhaps
standardization is the wrong word but
some amount of convergence where you
know the market hadn't you know for a
long time hadn't been that well served
by projects that did that but
additionally is that our visions are
much grander right like tracing and
metrics is just the start we we
eventually want to bring in blogs errors
profiling software you know any other
signals that we can bring in I want to
say that open census is a cross tech
instrumentation framework what we mean
by cross tech is we actually propagate
some dimensions we call them tags so you
can have you know multiple different
perspectives to take a look at your
instrumentation data these tags are
arbitrary things for example you can ask
questions like you know give me all this
metrics come in originated at this
particular service or give me all the
metrics that has been originated by this
specific customer so the goal is
actually have the tag propagation in
place and then you know multiple other
signal types can benefit from that have
you had like a really good response in
the community I think
people are generally extremely
interested because the gap is very clear
for most frameworks and libraries
there's absolutely no way to instrument
and they can literally see that you know
this project is filling that gap so the
response has been very positive because
we are addressing that nice good to have
the positive response already and you
said it was very new so it was in the
last month right that this was actually
announced yeah we announced it I think
last month it's been almost a month or a
couple of weeks yeah we're having
basically like a rolling launch yes
we're making more and more noise we're
going to more and more conferences and
we're making blog posts and just sort of
trying to ramp up the level of attention
that the project casts jbt you did a
talk at cube town didn't you we did
actually we did a together this project
and I followed up with other talks I
think there's a lot of work in order to
explain the concepts we have why we
solve the things the way we do before
giving them maybe the solution
so we're thinking about also spending
some time you know educating this about
these concepts and our library
implementations are still kind of like
work in progress and we sometimes break
API so we want to be in a very stable
situation before we start you know
widely talking about this project and
recommending it for the you know general
use great is there anything else that
you would want to plug around actual
talks or other efforts or community
involvement that's coming up we have a
bunch of talks coming up Morgan as
velocity Kampf talk in June I think
we've got velocity we've also made
applications for it and of course
because we haven't heard back yet
I'm pretty confident we'll get into most
of these at Kubik on SR week on monitor
Rama and then additionally some of the
Google specific conferences like GCP
next to Google i/o basically wherever
good presentations are found are
conferences that we should be at but
maybe you haven't applied to but we're
trying to go to as many as we can
wonderful and if people are keen to
either get involved or start playing
with open census where should they go
they should go on open census that IO
and you know take a look at our github
organization
I will put the links to your dock so you
know check out our specs and language
implementations and you know give it a
try we have enough guidelines about
getting started and can just try to use
it and give us feedback that will be
very appreciated at the stage and I'm
seeing here as well there's a 2018
Google of Summer of Code that is also
true we have several ideas so if you're
interested take a look at the list
contact us should they also send you
examples of how they're using it and
things that they're finding with it oh
yeah that would be awesome we actually
seen a bunch of you know blog posts
already from you know several users so
it would be totally so nice if you can
write any guidelines or you know in the
tips if you can write conceptual
documentation that would be also nice
I'm also trying to spend some time this
week just you know like write more
documentation for the website we will
have like soon more you know conceptual
docs and so on but you know any help
would be you know highly appreciated
great well we really appreciate you both
taking your time to come and talk to us
and share what open since this is is
there anything that you still wanted to
mention before we we close this out
contributors contribute all right well
thank you again and thank you Mark for
really appreciate you taking the time
thank you so much thank you again Morgan
and JP it was great to talk to you about
open census it's always great to hear
about what kind of open source projects
are going on and and how they're being
supported so mark I think now it's time
to ask you the question of the week I
heard that there are abilities to
natively extend kubernetes what does
that mean and also how do I do that cool
so yeah I can now talk more Phil thing
about go ahead it's in the work I've
been doing in that space I have a whole
bunch of questions the Wicker and
kubernetes which are really nice it's
very helpful yeah I want to give the
short answer here but I'm gonna put a
lot of resources in the show notes
because it's there's a bunch of stuff
around and some of this can be a little
bit hard to find so it but it's
something I want to talk about so yeah
so what does it mean to natively extinct
Reuben Eddy's essentially this means
that kubernetes has the ability to
essentially add endpoints to the
underlying API which then propagates out
so if you want to add your own nouns
to kubernetes for example so you know
how we have deployments and pods and
things like that
kubernetes has these things called
custom resource definitions which you
can configure and install through yamo
files of the api to add your own nouns
so if you want to add an ACME or a foo
or a widget or whatever that thing is
that you can then store configuration
information against you can do that
inside kubernetes um I'm gonna add some
more links but you can do that through
custom resource definitions and the
second part is a set of things but
probably either heard of either
controllers or operators I tend to use
the term controllers just because that's
the one I prefer but those are the
things that are custom pieces of code
you can put inside creepy entities to
react to when custom resource
definitions or other things really
anything happens inside kubernetes so
you may have seen there's like a
memcache D operator I've seen Redis
operators I've seen a bunch of different
ones around they're gonna is itself has
custom resource definitions for game
servers and a controller for that but
that combination combined means that
suddenly you can install this stuff into
communities I can then go cube CTL get
game server for example with okones and
it shows up in a natively inside
kubernetes I even get code completion
too which is cool if I look at the API
points I can see that extra stuff has
been added all that stuff is native
inside kubernetes like you can take
advantage of security it's all really
really cool stuff stuff I'm really
excited about but with those two things
those are the two keywords that you're
looking for there but I'm gonna put a
bunch of stuff in the show notes with
some video resources links to articles
all the different go libraries that
usually think you can use for all this
kind of stuff too so this is stuff that
you're interested in you'll have a nice
little resource there great well I think
that about does it for this week mark is
there anywhere where people are gonna be
able to find you in the near future
absolutely so I can talk now about all
the things I'm doing at GDC because it's
gonna ease out which is lovely yeah yeah
so GDC I'll be at the booth I'm doing a
half-hour talk at the booth we'll put
links to where that is and when that is
in the show notes it's on Wednesday at
camera but the exact time unfortunately
we're talking at the booth about
organize will be doing a sponsored talk
as well same thing we'll be doing a
what's new in firebase and Google cloud
so I'll be talking about that we're also
sponsoring the women games international
party so I'll just be there hanging out
we're doing meet the expert sessions I
think that's probably about it yeah but
I'll be all around GDC if anyone wants
to find me just hit me up on Twitter or
email or LinkedIn and that's all next
week
that's all next week yes now you
so excited yes part of me is really I
loved EDC a lot of me is very excited
for because there's so much guts really
happy for it to be over
well we'll talk about what you're gonna
do to relax once you're done but I'm
glad your big week is ahead of you yeah
are you going anywhere doing anything no
I'm going to rest
excellent take care of yourself hey well
alright well I think that does it for us
for this week yeah Melanie thank you for
joining me for yet another episode of
the podcast oh thank you
and thanks to everyone for listening and
we'll see you all next week
[Music]
[Music]